[Music]
that's real good work hi I'm Bob
emerging technologies like the
smartphone can be difficult to master
that's why we've created this
instructional series to give you the
tools you need to join the cutting edge
[Music]
tech stick you've heard a lot about it
now it's your turn to communicate
quickly easily and with total control so
remember this Golden Rule texting is
typing let's start with a simple example
say your daughter-in-law Melissa forgot
your birthday texting is a real easy way
to let your son know that his wife is
again being thoughtless simply draw your
son Tony in with a leading question Oh
see now you write your direct response
she forgot my birthday yesterday huh
my son says that the birthday greeting
that he's saying yesterday was meant to
be from the both of them well in a
situation like this you may want to
remind your son that it was you who paid
for rent and tuition during the first
two years of grad school and that he or
she has done nothing with that
particular degree ah see now smart he's
trying to change the game plan by making
this a phone call do not pick up bide
your time by eating some butterscotch
hard candy and watching a news magazine
let your son's guilt fester until it
forms a permanent Fisher and his
marriage with your daughter-in-law you
see how great texting can be and you
were worried all you have to do now is
sit back and enjoy the technology
experience
[Music]